[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast my friend best-selling author
state department alum teach for america
alum
uh
author of industries of the future and
his new book the raging 20s professor
alec ross alex
it's great to be here it's great to be
here andrew
well it's good to see you alec last time
i saw you you were running for governor
of maryland which is something that i
can relate to not that i run for
governor of maryland
yeah
yeah i know i i ran and you know look
i'm speaking to you from bologna italy
um
and it's not because i'm the governor of
maryland
[Laughter]
i know the feeling no
um i i i've had i've lost a race or two
in my time um but it's one of the things
that sets you apart is that there are a
lot of people that have
talked about the issues and problems but
you've served in a much more direct
mode than just about anyone where you
started your career as a teacher in
baltimore right that's right yeah no
booker t washington middle school taught
sixth graders
so and you went from there uh
eventually to the state department where
you saw the world and represented the
united states for a number of years
under the obama administration yeah it
was sort of a crazy path you know i was
teaching in inner city baltimore and
this was this was a legitimately like
really really rough neighborhood um you
know i grew up in coal country in west
virginia and coming out of college i
wanted to
i wanted to learn about urban america i
guess a little bit i went to
northwestern but joined teach for
america and had a great time in my
classroom but this was back in the mid
90s and like everybody else i was
witnessing the rise of the internet and
you know the transition of the economy
from being dominantly industrial based
into into increasingly technology rich
and knowledge based
it's like my kids have got to learn my
students have got to learn how to use
technology if they're going to get good
jobs in the future so between teaching
and going into the obama administration
i started a non-profit um that actually
worked in the state senate district
where barack obama was a state senator
on the south side of chicago so that's
how i got to know him and when he
decided to run for president i was like
this technology guy this techy
entrepreneur guy he knew and so
he recruited me first to help him run
for
the united states senate and then i ran
tech policy for his presidential
campaign and that's sort of what brought
me into
his orbit working for him for six years
four of which i work for hillary clinton
at the state department
so when you first met barack obama you
were like wow this guy's going places uh
is that what the experience was it was
you know state senate it's funny because
i had a colleague um
who
had absolutely no interest in meeting
it's like a state senator south side of
chicago it's like oh my god you know i
have no interest in meeting this guy
alec hugo
um and i met and i met him and i did see
you know obama is not a perfect human
being none of us are but i did see this
sort of otherness i saw what was special
on him and i was kind of like jesus the
dude's a state senator and he'd just
come off of getting his butt kicked
running for congress i mean he had
gotten he'd gotten whooped running for
congress against a
knucklehead
and but i was still like there's
something special here got crushed
running for congress he'll he'll be a
real good state senator maybe you'll do
something beyond that and the rest is
history
oh and am i right that you're you met
your wife while you were
a teacher or that um that she also was
in the classroom is that right
so yeah i'm totally inappropriate deeply
inappropriate she was the teacher across
the hall and we taught the same students
i was teaching
social studies and reading and she was
and she was teaching on math and we
taught the same students we tried to
keep it we tried to keep it on the
because neither download
was supervising the other this is just
straight-up colleague romance right i
mean that's legit
yeah i i i like to think of it that way
and you know what she's still in the
classroom so she is she's in teaching in
baltimore's public schools
literally as you and i speak here andrew
she's she's teaching she's teaching in
in these rough schools in baltimore and
doing a great job of it
oh one of the passages in your new book
the raging 20s that really hit me
was you are
harsh towards teachers unions and their
impact
from your direct experience as a teacher
where you were like hey i was excited to
join the union i'm like a big labor
person
but then in practice like i saw that
they weren't really helping my kids get
better results they seemed to be looking
out for teachers that were
fouling up
i mean
it's actually some pretty bad i mean
it's pretty rough examples of this i'm
gonna be honest you know a lot of you
know sort of the cool kids you know sort
of the hipster lefties will say oh you
know we have to sort of deify our unions
you know for lots of different reasons
but having been a part of the teachers
union in baltimore i saw them at i saw a
teacher's union sort of at its most
malignant you know so
you know they were not doing anything
necessarily to help teachers teach their
students and in fact teachers who had no
business being in the classroom were
those who they defended you know you
have sex with a 14 year old girl
teachers union is there to support you
you've got
a problem with heroin addiction that you
brought into the school with you
teachers union is there to make sure you
stay in the classroom
um you know somebody wants a principal
wants to set up a voluntary program that
you know would have teachers in the
school for 20 more minutes uh of the
school day and the teachers union would
fight violently against that so i'm not
anti-union i'm actually incredibly
pro-union and pro-worker but i do
believe that a lot of america's unions
including the vast majority of our
teachers unions frankly a lot of our
public sector unions
do
their do the people who are working with
and for them a disservice and they make
our communities worse off so i think we
need sort of a 2020 we need
in the same way in which we can sort of
have startups and innovate in the
technology world so too do i think we
need to get back to
having startups and innovating back in
the world of unionization and workers
movements
well it's tough to argue with your
perspective given that you spend years
in the classroom and so you saw it up
close and certainly when i ran for mayor
i had my issues with the teachers unions
and andrew i did see the opposite though
like i worked so when i was in west
virginia i was growing up in west
virginia i worked on a beer truck and um
the guys who drove the trucks were
teamsters
and those dudes were
remarkable like the the trucks would
roll out of the warehouse at six o'clock
in the morning there would be 13-hour
days these guys were like the strongest
human beings on planet they worked like
dogs and they earned a good wage and you
know people would literally go through a
program where they would sort of
apprentice for years so that they could
become teamsters and being a teamster
driving these beer trucks in west
virginia held the steam you could feed
your family you could go on vacation you
could get a new speed boat every five
years or so and so i've seen the good of
unions and i've seen the bad of unions
well they've been a path the middle
class for a lot of people but i'm
friends with andy stern who used to run
the seiu
and the thing that that is inarguable
that you also point out in your book
is that union membership has been on the
decline for years and years and decades
and decades and so it's difficult then
to try and turn back the clock and say
hey you're going to go from whatever it
is 12 of workers to
40 of workers again i mean that there
was a heyday when it was 40 of workers
and then it's declined ever since uh and
one of the frustrations i'd have
is that we're not really clear-eyed
about the conversations we're having
around a lot of these issues and i think
your book does a great job of laying out
the case for what the reality is in a
lot of these contexts
and it's always a little bit more
nuanced and textured you know like
unions do some great things and unions
uh are problematic
but one thing i would say
is that unions can't be your primary
solution
if it's if it's gone from
you know 40 or 50 of the workforce to uh
10 to 12. no that's exactly right and
look we can't click our heels together
like dorothy and the wizard of oz and
say there's no time like 1955. like it's
just it's it's not happening um what's
weird what's interesting i don't think
it's weird but i find it interesting
is
unions and things that are sort of like
unions work councils actually work
pretty darn well in other parts of the
world so i said for example
i said on the board of directors of a
publicly traded swiss company
and we have a work council
which functions sort of like a union
and at the beginning of covid we were
figuring out what the implication of on
the business was going to be and you
know before you fire people with a work
council in switzerland you engage the
workers and you have sort of an open
transparent discussion with them
and you know we said you know g in order
for us to make it we may need to fire
you know x number of of employees and
what they came back to us was well how
about we fire nobody but everybody
including by the way you guys the board
members and the senior executives take a
pay cut of y percent that we calculated
and we'll ride this out together
and you know what it worked
i you know we it was it was cooperative
it was collegial nobody got fired we all
took a financial haircut for a little
while
and we came out and came out on the
other end together and stronger and i
see i see the
in central and northern europe i see
lots of really positive models uh for
how labor and capital can work together
and sometimes and sometimes they have
seats on the board so you know a lot of
times models the german companies have
uh shop workers on the board and it
changes it it changes the discussion at
the board so it becomes
less about just maximizing the last
penny of shareholder value the last
penny in the stock price
but it also becomes how do you help a
broader set of stakeholders within the
company
yeah i've seen that work wonders because
i've been in those board rooms uh i've
seen in the non-profit level if you have
someone who's like in the
community that the non-profit servings
raising their hand being like well this
is actually what we care about and then
[Laughter]
it's also true i think at some
universities they have student trustees
in these meetings
you know i just i believe in ownership
and incentives so you know one of the
things that's related to this that i do
i am a big believer in and silicon
valley has done this well and i would
love to see it in more parts of the
economy is more employer ownership and
more employee ownership
um you know i do believe that we are you
know
what's rooted in our dna in part is we
are motivated by the incentives placed
in front of us and it's part of why
communism and socialism failed is
because they try they created a work
with too few incentives to work better
to produce a more beautiful product to
create more delight uh
in society so i do believe in incentives
and one of the greatest incentives is
is you know being a sort of owner
operator or having a seat at the board
table you are part of a company's
governance
[Applause]
if you are staring at your screen right
now while you're listening to this
podcast
you're probably frying your eyes you're
definitely frying your eyes we all are
we still stare at screens all day long
and it's very harmful to our eyes
and that's why we want you guys to check
out felix gray because it's good for you
and it looks cool these are the blue
light glasses that started it all so
five years ago they realized that our
eyes are not made to look at screens all
day and they design glasses to make
daily screen time more comfortable in
the work day more productive and frankly
they look really cool so you can go to
felixgrayglasses.com yang check it out
and you can actually do this augmented
reality thing where you can see the
glasses on your face before you try them
on so i do i tried a whole bunch i've
got a funky face so i use the ray-ban
shaped glasses but they're like tortoise
shell they're pretty freaking cool they
don't look like
safety goggles they kind of are um
they look cool but they help you and
they protect your eyes so we want you
guys to go to
com slash felixgrayglasses.com they've
got non-prescription and prescription
available you can check them out now
that's felix gray glasses
f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y
glasses.com
yang they got free shipping free returns
free exchanges felix grayglasses.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so after years in the state department
seeing the world you wrote this enormous
book industries of the future
uh based upon your
global survey essentially of what's
going on
and that that book was translated into
how many languages
think 24 24 languages
yeah it was a mega hit which did you
expect
[Laughter]
i don't know look i mean it would have
been awful i mean it's my first book i
had no i i had no idea what to expect i
mean i i think
and what i hope i did with this guy as
well what i hope i did with the raging
2020s as well is take this stuff that's
incredibly complicated
this sort of geeky
and make it more broadly accessible in a
way that also entertains um and and with
the industries of the future i mean it
ended up selling
you know
however many hundreds of thousands of
copies in part because i think a broader
a larger number of people want to
understand the things that are shaping
our future but don't but they aren't
engineers and they don't want to they
don't want to hear they don't
necessarily want to understand things at
the engineering level
it's the same with with this book the
raging 2020s the stuff that you and i
discuss andrew i think people want to
understand the forces that are shaping
our communities but don't necessarily
want to sit in a graduate class on
political theory right and and i wish
there were more books that were more
broadly accessible
so that's why i write what i do
yeah well i'm trying to trace your steps
a little bit so people have a sense of
your progression and perspective because
i find it fascinating too i mean you've
had one of the most interesting careers
of
uh of anyone i know
um so you come out with this mega hit
book what year was that that was in
2016.
so not that long ago uh and then there
there is this massive demand for your
time at this point because everyone's
like oh we got to get the guy wrote this
book in here to tell me
about how to how to develop our economy
um i i expect
uh so you
went globetrotting again i'm sure for at
least at least that that's what people
wanted you to do um but then you decided
to run for governor of maryland and
that's a deeply personal decision you
know you know you have a family and the
rest of it uh you know your wife's
teaching in the schools what was that
decision like
you know it's it's interesting it was
motivated in substantial part by the by
the time i had spent on the road so you
know i write this book in february of
2018.
much of the next in 2016 much of the
next year and a half is flying to like
dubai then hong kong then zurich you
know all of these sort of global centers
of power and capital
and seeing how and you know look the
people who would hire me to come out
would be you know
heads of investment banks or heads of
state or these people and i paid really
close attention uh trying to remember i
only had one mouth but two ears
tried to pay really close attention
to what was going on in the global
economy and you know be a fly in the
wall for all these discussions around
the world
and i was sort of terrified bluntly you
know
i had a similar experience uh
domestically but proceed no it's look
it's a world of heads i win tales you
lose i mean it's it's it's remarkable
and i gotta i'm just gonna be completely
uncensored with you andrew i've
experienced it myself once you get to a
certain level of wealth and i'm not like
super rich but once i got into the one
percent
um
just the way capital appreciates
it basically
guarantee when you get to a certain
point it guarantees that you are a
financial winner
um unless you do something really
self-destructive and so i saw these guys
you know these hedge fund managers and
these investment bankers and people
working in real estate
and they were lo there was literally no
consequence for their mistakes you know
if they were building a tower in dubai
and it went bust you know the llc they
incorporated to build that tower you
know went away and they went on to the
next tower in abu dhabi uh with a hedge
fund say they have a really bad year
well they had a really bad year but you
earn two percent against the four
billion dollars you have under assets
under management and simultaneous to
this i'm still a public school kid from
west virginia so here i am you know i
spent you know six years working for
obama traveled over four forty countries
you know all over the world then spend
this period sort of globetrotting
for the industries of the future and
what it did is it's it radicalized me a
little bit um or a lot
right
recognizing that our capitalism was
totally rigged
and that it was it was a winner takes
all model and the winners were
concentrated within this sort of one to
two to maybe three percent of society
and you hung out with enough of the
winners to be like wow these people are
not all awesome
no
you know and it's it's it's look that's
true so this is you know i i do believe
that the very concept of merit is
um
is worth discussing you know what i do
i've come to sort of
believe that talent is universally
distributed but opportunity is not
talent is everywhere opportunity is not
and i'm certain that the kids that i
went to school with
the public in the public school in west
virginia were an equal in talent to a
lot of those folks who i would say in
singapore or dubai or geneva they were
just a completely different set of
circumstances or they had a different
last name and a rich daddy and so this
contributed to the radicalization like
you see
they aren't awesome and in many cases
they aren't even that smart they're just
in a heads i went to you don't have to
be very smart when it's heads i win
tales you lose like you're going to win
every time
well this is one of the quotes i i took
from your book talking about the
meritocracy the parallel cultural
politics of meritocracy that equates
economic success with moral worth and
social esteem
is a dangerous force in politics because
it means that when inequality rises not
only people do people get poorer they
also get angrier
and i think that a lot of people can
relate to that right now where uh the
myth of the meritocracy is being
progressively shattered in multiple ways
i think that pandemic had a lot to do
with it where
people were cut off from
sources of income and it had nothing to
do with merit it just had to do with uh
what kind of job you had
no that's exactly right and
you know i i i'm sorry to keep coming
back from what to west virginia but for
me it's just it's really instructive you
know when i was growing up in the 1970s
and 1980s it was sort of the center of
sort of union democrats i mean michael
dukakis
won west virginia i think he won like
massachusetts west virginia and maybe
one other state or something like that
but it went from the politics of sort of
union democrats to
the politics of
really really loving donald trump um and
you know all of the many trumps that are
out there and with a lot of the sort of
associated anger and i've i have come to
believe that a lot of that anger
comes from as people struggle
financially
and as
their place their standing in the world
decreases
um as we define success differently
it's it sets people off on a on a what
can be a really scary
uh emotional and intellectual road
so you clearly have deep roots in west
virginia do you still have family there
do you get back there
i do my parents are there i've got i've
got aunts and uncles uh so yeah i know
you know i was i was back there last
month in fact
well for me i like we i had a uh an
experience
um that i i think hearkens to yours
where uh my parents immigrated to this
country from
taiwan they met as graduate students at
berkeley uh i was born in skin activity
in new york my dad worked for ge um so
if you're the first generation born in
this country uh growing up in uh in
schenectady and then
um
the suburbs of new york city
uh you just grow up watching the same tv
you did because i think we're
contemporaries and there's kind of like
a mono culture and we're all sort of in
it together
and
you kind of have a sense of perspective
and and then in my case
no uh when i was running venture for
america
i ran in high level circles of
government and philanthropy and
entrepreneurship and tech and hanging
out with these folks i was
dismayed
radicalized where i was like okay like
this stuff's not going to do it at all
like when you're in the room with the
people who are supposed to be running
things or managing things or fixing
things and you see that they don't
actually have any interest in fixing
most of the things that you see around
you
and your globe trotting for me it was
crisscrossing
uh michigan ohio alabama louisiana
missouri like all these states i'd never
spent any time in growing up in the east
coast
um and so after i saw these environments
i was i and then
uh this was before trump won
um trump winning
was a giant red flag for me as it sounds
like it was for you and that was around
this time when you're seeing the world
so you come back and decide to to run
for governor because you think that well
the problems are getting worse and maybe
i can help
no that's exactly right and
you know i just and also andrew i feel
like we needed people from our
generation to step forward a little bit
and you know i i knew going in uh
running for governor would be a long
shot
but you know i'm one of those guys who
you know
says you know we we need to take risks
every now and that you know if i regret
anything it's the chances it's the
things i didn't try to do rather than
mistakes i made when i did do it and so
i sort of
you know i i followed my own gospel a
little bit and got into a race that you
know that i probably wasn't going to
want win and and it ended up that i
didn't win but i'm glad in the end that
i did run because the message got out
there it helped create a little bit of a
movement
and uh
you know look we can't leave politics to
the politicians you know we have to we
have to force ourselves in there and and
honestly i think about barack obama you
know again when i met barack obama he
had just gotten his he had just gotten
his butt kicked running for congress he
had sort of made a deal with michelle
that he would right he would get one
more run and if he didn't and if he
didn't win then he would take that
corporate lawyer job or in the
foundation job or something like that
and lo and behold he he shoots up
everybody thought he was insane
insane there were all these
interventions you know telling him that
you know having gotten his butt kicked
running for congress he had no business
running for the senate
and his audacity was rewarded so i do
think i we i think we have to be
audacious every now and then you know i
think about theodore roosevelt who said
you talked about staying out of the
great twilight he said it's far better
to make to dare mighty deeds to win
glorious triumphs even though checkered
by failure than to rank with those poor
spirits who neither enjoy much nor
suffer much because they dwell in a gray
twilight that knows neither victory nor
defeat and so andrew one thing i'd like
to think that you and i have in common
is that we'd like to suffer much or
enjoy much rather than be in sort of the
great twilight
i think it's that we both married well i
like we have partners who are willing to
put up with our our mad cap
yeah that's a pretty like that's
approved that's a prerequisite it
doesn't work without that
it doesn't work without that
well so i i understand both the joys and
uh the trials of running a campaign it
takes a lot out of you i don't think
most people appreciate just how much it
takes out of you uh and i wish that
people took it more to heart because
it's easy
to say like oh this person uh you know
like
they they
uh they lost or you know like uh i
didn't like this about their campaign
it's like if if there's someone and
there's a journalist in new york
um who
had run for office and had a completely
different perspective as a result and so
he was like hey
so
that was something i appreciated about
him crystal ball is another journalist
who's run for office like if you've run
for office
it's very very
uh personal um it can't help but be
personal and this is something that i
discovered running for president
um was i likened it to entrepreneurship
because you and i both started
organizations and so you're like yeah
this will be like that um but when you
start an organization
uh you're not the product
in the same way that it is when you run
for office
and when you are the product then you
have to be on
uh in a different way
than even an entrepreneur would have to
be
no it's the personalization of the exp
the degree to which it's a deeply
personal experience is something i could
not have understood
without running you know i'd been
involved in campaigns before i ran tech
policy for obama's first presidential
campaign
um
there's nothing to analog there's no
part of being a st staff in a campaign
that can help people understand sort of
the mental space of being the candidate
because and so much
of what's being judged too
that was tough for me is not the quality
of the policy or the ideas
but it's all of this sort of deeply
personal stuff it's like oh you know
i don't like his hair or why you know
gosh he's he's too short to be a
governor or you know it's all of these
really
you know funny things about somebody's
laugh or whatever it is you know it's
it's
it's it's and you're judged like you're
judged like a middle s like middle
schoolers are judged in many respects
it's like going back to being 13 and 14
years old
oh my god i'm a serious dog
but you're judged like you're 13 or 14
years old and
as you said you're the product and you
can't really back off you can't really
ease back at all like you know when you
walk into a room
you're you're essentially selling
yourself you're trying to convey why you
as a person
are
a solution to some of the problems that
that are being articulated by the people
in the room it's it is a it's a
disorienting experience and the thing
that worries me a little android and i'd
be curious to know what you think about
this
you've run a couple times i really hope
you run for something again
but it seems to me like when you do this
when people do this every two years or
every four years forever um
it does seem to create this sort of
psychosis like it does create this
i mean imagine doing this
10 or 15 times like how do you not
become
just a complete egomaniac it's it's sort
of strange i don't know
yeah it'll twist you i actually write a
chapter about this in my upcoming book
that i'll send your way
uh thank
you uh it called power screws with you
with your mind
and and it's not even so much power
because it's not like you have that much
power as a candidate but uh
but just always being in the spotlight
always being on
uh and then there are people around you
that theoretically work for you but
they're telling you where to go and what
to do and what to say a lot of the time
and so you become something of an
automaton uh and your genuine empathy
erodes and there are studies that
indicate this so i think you're you're
right that our political class
tend to be missing a certain something
over time
because of the process and i think the
process has gotten worse of late because
of uh social media and the nature of uh
the news cycles
i think you're right i mean and it's
interesting too like
if you just think about our politicians
for a second
today you know when i was growing up
when we were growing up the most media a
politician would get would be whatever
was in the daily newspaper or on like
the local news station um
now with social media they're sort of on
all the time
and
it's created this sort of strange
panopticon um
with the ego at the center of it and
and that's why i think we see more sort
of
crazy politicians too like we see people
who
love that you know it's like sarah palin
like there are now 30 sarah palin's in
in congress
um where she was very distinct 10 years
ago because social media i think in part
well i'm not anti-social media by any
any stretch i do think that the
combination of money and politics with
the amplification from social media and
other such things
bring
brings in and helps enable
um
some strange personalities
it's very dark uh like i mean you're
you're a very
high character human i've known you for
years uh and you're exactly the sort of
person that we would need to have in
very high office
that
uh
right now our system is not necessarily
going to embrace uh you know it's just
and you and i might know some other
people like us though
many of them are
um
too wise to run for office
right
right
which is part of the problem where
you're like well you kind of need to do
it but then they look at it and be like
hey i see the bizarreness the ringer the
unfairness like the rest of it um and
you know sometimes their family's not
into it like there are a lot of
variables
um but you and i would be like yeah do
it
yes we would look and also it's also
true andrew only optimists changed the
world so yeah like we talked about this
like it could make you want to curl into
the fetal position
but only optimus changed the world and
so i i do you know the political it's
really hard to break in politically
right now or for
people with new ideas for people who
aren't part of a sort who aren't part of
sort of the good old boys network or
good old gals network to break in but i
am choosing to be optimistic and and i
believe in the power of books like i
believe that this book of yours that's
coming out at the beginning of october
can really move a lot of people you know
i they i
haven't even
seen it yet but thank you for saying no
ideas do move the world i mean you
mentioned the industries of the future
my last book i mean there were five
different presidents or prime ministers
who recommended that book to their
people
and you know like publicly um
from literally from the president of
pakistan to benjamin netanyahu and let
me tell you there are no two people who
are more different than those two
and so i am choosing
while i'm not running for office now the
reason why i'm writing is because i do
believe that books matter that ideas
matter
and it's one way to sort of
shape the world in some modest way
[Music]
folks we cannot stress this enough
if you have not put any
intention or focus
on your mental health
i want you to stop right now and think
about ways you can do so and i want to
encourage you and challenge you to do so
and one of the best ways you can do that
is through our sponsor betterhelp um i
can't rave about them enough i use
betterhelp once a week um i go to my gal
i guess i'll name her i'll keep her
nameless but i call it my steam valve
because every once a week i blow off
steam um by talking to somebody and
for me it's helped with like
professional focus and my relationships
both family and
girlfriends and everything um but it's
a way to
focus on something that really really
matters is just how we navigate the
world every day so whether it's
depression stress anxiety relationship
sleeping trauma anger family conflicts
you name it you could talk about these
securely professionally online available
24 7 you can start connecting instantly
within under 48 hours it's super
convenient it's secure it's fantastic so
we want you to start living a happier
life today and taking charge your mental
health and as a listener you're going to
get 10 off your first month by visiting
our sponsor
betterhelp.com so join over 1 million
people including us who have taken
charge of their mental health again
that's betterhelphelp.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you are an activist at heart and
your new book
uh
the raging i'm calling the raging 20s
but i guess you called it the raging
2020s is that correct yeah but you can
call it the raging 20s
all right so so your new book makes a
very clear
case
that uh what we believe was our social
contract has uh degraded and
deteriorated on multiple fronts and you
point to a few of the holes in it
uh with the the first one being
the the distortions of shareholder
capitalism where companies used to
care about something other than just a
share price but then a number of years
ago
harvard business school said nope just
the share price
that a lot of things have kind of uh
come with that and right now they're
seeing how bad it is and saying we
should probably go back to something
broader
with stakeholder capitalism being the
uh the term
um and i've been in conferences where
jamie dimon and other people have made
the case for
uh stakeholder capitalism um where they
see the inequalities are are reaching
epic proportions uh
so you go into that case in detail which
i agree with um and you you say that
companies do need to embrace broader
notions of who they're responsible to
yeah i mean look
the american economy boomed
boomed for decades um after world war ii
when we really modeled
what we now call stakeholder capitalism
and then what happened really in the 80s
um it re you know
it really really accelerated during the
80s it then became sort of intellectual
doctrine
uh in the 1990s
shareholder capitalism is really what
has
taken most of america's workers and put
them in such a
position of weakness relative to where
they were 30 years ago and it's
interesting
uh you know i mean decades ago if a
company
were in a little bit of trouble
um it wouldn't immediately fire workers
because it viewed itself as having a
commitment to its workers sometimes a
multi-generational
commitment to its workers and this was
especially true when you know look when
you were in schenectady and i was in
charleston west virginia every
medium-sized city or larger in america
had a headquarters then what happened
with shareholder capitalism what
shareholder capitalism basically
compelled it said is hey you need to
become tax optimized you know if iowa or
west virginia or new york state or ohio
or michigan are not the optimal tax
locations for your company then you are
compelled to move it to texas or move it
to florida or move it to delaware
and as these companies moved part of
what happened was
the children of the children of the ceo
that may have used to go to school with
the children of the middle manager
that was no longer the case
the companies that would have you know
been in that town in iowa or that town
in michigan or wherever
that would have supported the united way
and
the little league and the local symphony
once they moved to delaware months that
once they moved to some tax optimized
location that didn't happen anymore
so part of what we're seeing and you can
see this if you sort of look at a map
actually of
where donald trump has done well
a lot where donald trump did well
electorally a lot of it maps to the
places
where they shift from stakeholder to
shareholder capitalism was most brutal
and it's not a coincidence for example
that in agricultural america um that's
where a lot of the
the blood gets up the most where the
most anger is
and in my book the raging 2020s a lot of
what i write about is
agricultural and rural america and what
the effects of corporatization have been
there it's it's it's really malignant
it is you've seen an emptying out of a
lot of
the midwest in in various ways and those
areas have gone red
ohio used to be the quintessential swing
state obama won it i want to say he won
it twice
um and it went to trump by eight points
i think also twice
and then so
uh and you know i have friends from ohio
and i thought of ohio as
well they thought of ohio was very very
purple it's it's been difficult for them
to see it swing the this direction
um
you also
uh talk about and this was really really
compelling to me you you talk about how
there's been a brain drain out of public
service and you saw it in your time in
government where a lot of the ultra
talented people you worked with
went to tech companies uh went to
silicon valley
uh and
that's going to be very difficult to
undo uh since
industry
tends to be and you you make a case too
that was wild where you say look it's
more efficient it pays more and you
might even have more power
i was like whoa that's a strong
statement no it's nuts look i mean
what happens is you know you go to
college you come out of college and
you're some earnest young person who
wants to change the world and you go to
work for government
then this thing happens you know after a
number of years when you get to about
age 30 where you realize that you can
literally triple
not 3 not 30 but 300 percent
what you earn
uh you massively diminish the number of
hours you work you have you're working
with better computers and a lot more
efficiently and as i as i said andrew
you can actually have more power
because
with the brain drain out of government
people in government are increasingly
relying on those outside experts to
drive what happens inside government and
so it i think the average number of
hours worked by a house of
representative staffer is over 80 hours
a week and they leave on average by
their 31st birthday so what that means a
lot of the time is that the people who
put in their time and then continue to
work
outside of government retain or maybe
even increase the amount of power they
had
driving what's actually going on inside
government it's a fascinating dynamic
yeah i had a friend uh i grew up with
who worked on capitol hill and he said
going in i'm never going to be a
lobbyist and then fast forward x years
later he is a lobbyist
and
and the the
calculus was not this similar to what
you just described which is his
lifestyle is better his pay is better he
uh
does as
uh impactful work
uh on the outside but the the thing that
struck me is that you've worked for the
government and you know if you include
teaching in the public sector for
a decade or more
and you characterize the weakness of the
state in a particular way and the talent
is part of it
um
i agree with this
analysis by the way
and there's something where
our government has become this kind of
behind the curve
uh flopping bureaucracy
uh and we're
demanding more and more of it and
getting more and more frustrated
uh and the conversations around what the
government can do are becoming more and
more incoherent
and
and there are all of these fears around
overreaching of the state
um where i'm concerned more about
our ability to actually address
things like climate change or whatever
like the crisis of the day is or
the the crisis i was running on which
was
the automation of labor and uh a labor
market that's going to kick more and
more people to the curb which we're
seeing in different forms
right now
and this is one thing i wanted to have a
head-to-head with you or like a heart to
heart is that you've been part of public
service you ran for governor yeah and
there's part of me that
you know i'm not sure what the the scope
of the governor's powers are in maryland
um did you ever fear that uh that you
get the office and aren't able to do a
lot of the things that
that you want to do like that this to me
is one of the great concerns because i
run a non-profit i ran for
for president because i saw the limits
of what you can do in the nonprofit
space
and
one one of the issues that you and i
have is that we know a lot of private
sector actors and like i have a very
deep appreciation for
the power of the private sector
uh the private sector is going to try
and solve certain problems not others it
doesn't care about certain problems that
you're not going to make any money off
of so so then we're like okay let's try
and solve these non-market problems who
are gonna turn to
the government and then the government
may or may not be able to deliver uh
it's one reason why i ran on something i
thought the government could deliver
which is cash because
that's something no there was there was
a
commentator who said our government is
bad at many many things but it's
excellent at sending large numbers of
checks promptly
every
every month uh so
yeah so i wanted to unpack your analysis
of the the weaknesses of the musculature
of the state yeah so look i think there
are three things that are holding us
back
one we talked about is brain drain you
know if you are a highly talented person
there are all of these incentives for
you to leave government and you know in
the book i give the example of how
that's being compatible for example in
singapore where they pay
their career civil service really well
um you know analogous to their private
sector peers so one is is brain drain
two is clegocracy and three is vetocracy
so what are they clutchocracy is the
government has become so complicated
um and so ungovernable that you know
clutch you know we basically are putting
what are analogous to like software
patches uh into all of our public policy
solutions like the the infrastructure
bill that's in front of congress right
now it is physically impossible to read
that it is something like two feet
three feet tall
in terms of the amount of paper that's
there i mean that is that is
unmanageable
and then vitocracy which is obvious
which you've discussed a lot which
you've discussed a lot before which is
just given the
given the degree to which the united
states is a divided country it makes it
very hard to achieve any sort of
compromise what i will say so i think
that those are the three things holding
government back but i will say this
based on my time in government
especially in the executive branch and
there's a reason why i ran for governor
and not for congress i i will never i
will say definitively right here i will
never run for a legislative branch
office never
um because those executive branch jobs
actually really do have a lot of power
you can do a lot you know so for four
years i worked at the state department
and whether it was getting dissidents
out of jail whether it was you know
putting programs in place in the east
congo to help
uh prevent acts of sexual violence by
rogue militias whether it was putting an
internet freedom agenda in place you
actually can't have a lot of power so
long as
you are willing to exercise power and so
i went into it like an entrepreneur i
went into it sort of both guns blazing
and honestly it was because i had
protection from
the president and then from hillary
clinton who was the secretary of state
without the protection from on high i
probably couldn't have gotten away with
working with such a high risk profile
but they protected me and therefore i
was able to get a lot done but mine
mine may very well have been the
exception that proves the rule
yeah you sound exceptionally
uh impactful
no i don't i don't know i was a little
crazy and some of it worked inside
you know i think you have to bring a
little punk rock sometimes you know the
us government needs a little punk rock
right now
well you know one one of the issues is
that
there's a lot of frustration and then
it's getting manifest in trump uh and
what what you need is something
like what you offered or what i like to
think i offered which is like look like
i'm gonna bring some new energy um but
i'm not malignant
like i'm
like i'm i'm a non-i'm a non-like
lunatic
you're you're doing this for the right
reasons
you're not doing this because you want
to see somebody's head on a stick no
it's true
well and part of the issue politically
right now is that negativity sells um
though it's heartening to hear that
you're still encouraged by the
capacities
of the government if the government
could get some of these things cleared
up
that that's more optimism than a lot of
people have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sports have long been an important and
defining part of our history
with their impact and influence
key moments in sports have helped shape
heal
and inspire it has been said that i have
two alternatives
either go to jail
or go to the army
but i would like to say that there is
another alternative
that alternative is justice
i'm doc rivers and i'm proud to present
a new podcast documentary series called
it was said sports where i guide you
through six of the most impactful and
timeless speeches in sports history the
question has already been answered
should we be here
yes
listen and follow it was said sports a
documentary podcast presentation of
shining city audio a c13 originals and
john meacham studio available now
wherever you listen to your podcast
there's another part of the book that i
found very edifying because i did not
know about it to this extent which is
the the craziness of tax havens and
transfer pricing
[Laughter]
it's like the the game of monty that
tech companies and multinationals play
where they're they're not paying
meaningful tax
no it's look this is i think if this is
an incredibly boring topic
and it's incredibly important i mean i
do think that the issue of global tax is
sort of a skeleton key
for understanding why we live in a heads
i win tails you lose world um
the when i mean there have been years
where it is true where is literally true
that fedex the company
paid less than federal taxes than one of
their delivery drivers and a barista at
starbucks paid less in taxes than
starbucks corp
and for these tech companies with
transfer pricing
like they they literally will create
these shell companies where like google
netherlands
uh will sell its intellectual property
to google of the canary islands and send
it through and
basically say that the transfer of that
30 billion dollars uh
what is a cost and so what i do in the
the raging 2020s my my mind was so blown
by this i wanted to take a simple
transaction a belt
uh i literally somebody clicks on a
google ad
for a belt and i traced the transaction
for what happens with every cent when
what happens when somebody buys a belt
after clicking a google ad and i had
more economists accountants and lawyers
check every last cent in this story i
told about google and its belt so that
when google's lawyers you know
try to block the sale of the book
um they won't have a leg to stand on but
i do think that the thing that is most
complicated but in many respects most
important for us to solve
is this issue of global tax and again
i'll just make this really personal for
a second
um
last year
i think i paid less
as a percentage of my household income
than the 25 year old research assistant
who worked for me on this book and it's
because so much of what i made was a
function of increased capital as opposed
to like a paycheck it should be the
exact opposite
um
the wealthier you are the less taxes you
pay is a total percentage because
because you know the jeff bezos is the
world are not growing wealthy because
every two weeks they're getting a direct
deposit into their bank account you know
because of their salary at amazon it's a
function of increased capital and if you
are the least bit creative you can
legally and all of this is legal you can
legally avoid paying
just about any taxes it's fairly
remarkable
yeah so much of our society now operates
on this idea that government's going to
be three steps behind uh industry
in terms of being able to capture some
of this value
and so you know when you talk about
people paying their fair share i'm i'm
willing to consider a lot of relatively
dramatic changes on this i was proposing
a value-added tax which a lot of
european countries have to to try and
get it at the point of sale uh one of
the many things i enjoyed about your
book was your reference to some of the
models in other countries that you think
we could be emulating
um a lot of those countries are more
homogeneous in the united states would
you
note
and so that that's one of the challenges
is can we
implement some of those types of
safety nets or
other types of programs in
uh diverse society uh but i enjoyed the
fact that you were calling out things
that work in other countries because i
thought it was immensely constructive
what are the examples you feel most
strongly about from other parts of the
world
well uh one example i'll give is from is
from the nordic countries um
the nordic countries are actually
incredibly entrepreneurial they allow a
lot of flexibility and freedom uh within
their private sector but they also have
this very strong safety net um
and what it basically means is that if
there's any homelessness there um if
there's anybody who is unemployed or
unemployable uh
there are these the systems sort of
it's like you know that what like one of
those
um like one of those machines in the
matrix that just
you know gathers right on it sort of
attacks the problem systemically and
it's fascinating to watch you know just
the safety net is so strong there and
one of the things that i since you
brought up diversity andrew one of the
things that i think that you know the
thinking about for example ubi the
importance of the u in ubi
is
its universality and so part of what i
believe we've seen right now is that
when
if you want to make interventions in a
society um
the more broadly and the more universal
the benefits are
the less resentment it creates across
lines of
race ethnicity religion and what have
you so a lot of the benefits in the
nordic countries are universally
available it's not like oh you have free
child care if you make below 50 000
euros a year no
you get free child care if you make
below 50 000 or if you make over 5
million use a year a million years a
year so because the benefits are
universal there isn't this sort of
resentment that's going be that's that's
going from one group of people to
another so so i think for example when
we think about
ubi part of what is compelling about ubi
is the is is
it's the you
you know it's not
welfare it's not a cash it's not a cash
payment just to the the lowest income
people because what that then does is it
creates this really powerful political
and cultural divide between the lowest
income people and working class people
and middle class people and upper middle
class people and these differences are
keenly felt so the the an example i'll
point to is
the universality of benefits within the
nordics as opposed to
means testing and individualizing
everything we in the united states we
have a highly individualized social
contract
um and the degree and
because we've so hyper individualized
things we've really shredded
um a lot of the collective dimensions of
our social contract
i think we've hyper bureaucratized
things
uh and that's one of the problems where
it's punitive to wind up interacting
with some of these
programs and they're constantly checking
up on you and i i've talked to hundreds
of americans who live in fear of
something getting taken away from them
because they screw something up um and
that's that's almost deliberate you note
that in your book too where um you quote
someone talking about the relative
incoherence of a lot of the uh american
policy approaches
no i'd say look it's a it's a complete
mess it's a it's a when you have this
part of the byproduct of
individualization means you need
100 you need dozens and hundreds and
thousands of people to regulate and
bureaucratize the administrations of
these programs as opposed to as you were
saying earlier andrew like pushing a
button and sending a check
um you know we need to become our
government needs to become
more one button it needs to be more
we need to take the friction
out of most of our interactions with
government
amen you and i are going to help make
that happen so what are you most excited
about alec your book i was trying to
characterize it as
optimistic or pessimistic you're clearly
a very optimistic fellow anyone
listening to this hotel um yeah your
book paints i thought a relatively
uh accurate picture of some of the
problems
if there was an issue i have with your
book it's almost that you imagine that
there has been a social contract
that we're stretching
pardon me i was like we haven't had one
for a minute or two yeah yeah because
it's true in the 70s i mean it it it
existed empirically to a higher degree
um so but let's close
it's a great book um please do pick it
up uh if you're listening to this
um because you'll learn a lot
but what are you most excited about alec
and whatever comes next like i i would
love to work with you uh side by side
because you're a real force for progress
but what are you most excited about
thank you well look i'm most excited
about
this
generation of like 20 something
20-somethings and 30-somethings who have
sort of activated
who's uh who they're now part of the
solutions right like and a lot of them
are yan gang like a lot of them are
people who you got into the political
process so what i'm excited about is
we've been relying on generations
of people and and sort of a roving cast
of characters
um for a long time now i mean if you
like let's be this isn't about democrats
and republicans like i think we can be
really critical of democrats i mean if
you look at the at the senate and house
leadership in congress i mean
in the house i don't think there's
anybody below the age of 75
in the top ranks of leadership
and i think that that has not served us
well
i am most excited about these 20
somethings and 30-somethings and as time
passes their power is going to grow
that's what excites me
well that is very optimistic alec i'm
i'm with you on
uh different generations stepping up in
different ways i'm with you certainly in
that we could use a
cultural transformation
in government that's less
based on seniority
and i'm happy to say that these are some
things that i'm going to be working on
and hopefully again you and i'll have a
chance to work together on it
congratulations on a great achievement
with your book the raging 20s what comes
next for you aside from you're going to
be going on a book tour or whatnot um
you know i know at this point you you're
working on a number of things the
private sector you're a professor you've
got a growing family but like do you
have a sense at
as to what comes next no um
my eyes are wide open you know writing
this crazy book was sort of you know
it's like
i won't say it's like giving birth
because that will offend every woman
who's watching and it probably should um
but what i will say is it's a difficult
and process that takes a lot of time
so
look i i i'm just going to try to bring
uh like as i was saying bring a little
punk rock into the policy process try to
try to shake things up a little bit and
do so through look i have limited skills
there are three things i feel like i can
play in ideas doing that with a book
governance you know we'll see if i
engage uh back there again and
entrepreneurship so those are the three
things i sort of move between
those three worlds it reminds me a
little bit of you
all three of them need you it's what i
was saying
okay congrats alec and uh hopefully
uh this book will move a lot of hearts
and minds and we'll get some younger
people engaged so they can take over and
hopefully save us all
thank you andrew and thank you for
everybody who's watching in
[Music]
you